you and i were talking about movies that
uh where there's limitations put on what
the camera does or what the point of
view goes uh be it something like rope
or buried in recent years
um
a lot of people think that there's
freedom found in that restriction would
you agree with that absolutely i think
that if you have a limited environment
you know you're going to get all of it
and so it's a question of finding out
ways of
of capturing the whole thing
and
i
completely believe that no matter what
the film even if it's a big budget film
with with lots of special effects
the audience the the part of the screen
where the audience are looking is the
eyes of the actors i think
via gravity or you know like no matter
the setting it's the person in the
middle that's interesting and with this
one the person in the middle is tom
hardy and wow that's a fascinating
resource there um
what about this performance this movie
was written very quickly and filmed very
quickly too right yeah it sort of had a
bit of a charm life it was unlike
anything else i've ever worked on where
all the doors flew open
um for whatever reason but
i had the idea for doing something
different after i've made a more
conventional film
and wondered if there wasn't a different
way of getting people into a room turn
off the lights and have them engage with
the screen
i'd also
we tested the digital cameras by
shooting from moving vehicles and i
found the test footage absolutely um
hypnotic
and wondered if you couldn't turn that
into a theater and put an actor in
and shoot effectively a stage play one
of the best comments it comes out of
seeing is people forget they haven't
seen the other people
so
it's a question of you hear the voice
and you hear the sound effects of the
situation and i think it's a natural
human thing to then create the picture
like when you read a story to a kid or
when you listen to a radio play
that
people automatically begin to create
that world so
it was an attempt to try and engage with
whatever that facility is
and it seemed like um the conversations
they felt very authentic uh in their
cadence and the way they overlapped or
the emotion in them uh was there improv
was that a big part of your plan or was
that part or was that all
originally i thought
improvisation would be available or
should be available to the actors but
all of them who were all theater people
didn't want that they wanted to have
word for word so tom had teleprompt
on the low the car was on a low loader
there was teleprompt in front there's
teleprompter in the rear view and in the
gps so
wherever he wherever he looked the
script was and the actors had
the script with him but the great thing
about it is that as they all said as
theater people once they've got that
there they've got the words
solid nailed
then they can start to do what they do
because if it had been a question of you
know you start a phone conversation then
it might go that way or that way
i think the chaos would have entered the
car
we sat round the table with all of the
actors and tom for five days and just
read through as we would for theater and
and just talked about character and
motivation and all of those things so
that when we went on the road
we felt equipped to do the thing and
what we
um agreed to do from the beginning which
is what we did is to do it in a
different way where
tom was in the car on the low loader
with the teleprompt the actors were in a
hotel room with some red wine and a
phone line into the car
i would say action only once we would
set off we shot the whole film beginning
to end we'd have a break
shoot the whole film again have a break
and shoot the whole thumb again and have
a break so
we didn't want to at any point for me to
say can we go again
or can you do that differently but just
knowing that
it will be perfect in different places
every time and it will be wrong in
different places every time so that you
can then cut together where it's right
and at the end of each one have a
conversation maybe about one aspect of
it but it just meant that the actors
could calibrate their own performance so
when they get when it's emotional at the
end it's emotional because they've just
been through that
rather than and an actors obviously
because it's more of a theater
experience enjoy that him being sick and
things like that that comes across yeah
i mean but all along what we wanted to
do was capture what was really going on
so
i'd love to
claim that him having a bad cold was
textural but it's not it he arrived on
the day for filming he had a cold and
you allowed that well no
it was either
hide it or go with it and so we said
okay well ivan's got a cold so the
medicine that is taken is the medicine
that tom arrived on the set with